on savait qu'ils avaient dissidence
entre renaud lachance et francine
charbonneau dans le rapport de la
commission charbonneau sur les
conclusions qui touchait le financement
des partis politiques
les marie maude denis nous a révélé ce
soir à quel point la relation s'était
envenimée entre eux alors quel impact
auront ces révélations sur la
crédibilité du rapport j'en parle avec
daniel d'achat et michel bonsoir à vous
trois ans et alors c'est vraiment assez
énorme ce qu'on a appris aujourd'hui
j'aimerais avoir un peu votre première
réaction
michel c'est du jamais vu ou presque ah
ben moi j'ai jamais vu ça en tout cas
écouter j'imagine que dans toutes les
commissions il ya des discussions
serrées des dissensions à des
négociations mais là c'est une vraie
guerre à laquelle on assiste est de
toute évidence et une guerre dont cette
fuite là me semble être le dernier
épisode dans mon esprit est très clair
que les gens qui ont assez cool et les
courriels de monsieur lachance ça vient
de l'intérieur de la commission que
c'est des gens qui veulent qu'il a qui
veulent pas qu'ils l'emportent en
paradis qui est et qui veulent s'assurer
qu'il n'y aura pas de retour d'ascenseur
ne sait jamais on avait pensé lui donner
un emploi quelconque
je pense que c'est désormais exclue là
il est complètement discrédité sur ce
plan la tâche aussi un peu une bombe à
ouais mais c'est pas un pétard mots
c'est clair c'est un fêtard c'est
quelque chose très sérieux et je pense
que c'est oui ça discrédite discrédit
monsieur lachance mais aussi le rapport
parce que effectivement ça fait ça
sèment la suspicion de blanchissages
sacem une suspicion que monsieur
lachance avait un autre agenda peut-être
comme monsieur rouge il le dit protéger
un peu sa réputation comme quand on
était déjà c'est ça et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui ternit le
rapport c'est très dommage tout l'argent
qui a été dépensé là dessus pour venir à
bout de la situation et finalement on
maintenant on aurait toujours des doutes
toujours des doutes
daniel vous comment vous avez réagi en
attendant voyant ça c'est un fiasco je
pense que le mot n'est pas trop fort je
suis pas un adepte lui même horreur des
théories du grand clos mais j'en ai
entendu plusieurs aujourd'hui il y en a
qui sont évoqués plus sérieusement qu'il
vous faut dresser les cheveux sur la
tête
il faudra faire la preuve de tout ça la
chose qui me semble la plus importante
en ce moment c'est que monsieur lachance
s'explique pas nécessairement devant une
commission parlementaire de toute façon
ça n'arrivera pas les libéraux ne
permettront pas et c'est vraiment pas la
tribune pour ce genre de choses là et
qu'ils s'expliquent publiquement par la
voix des médias qu'ils le fassent en
conférence de presse qu'il le fasse
n'importe quelle façon
mais monsieur lachance doit cette
explication là à la population - michel
il doit cette explication pour l'instant
ayant rien n'est pas question il l'a dit
il la juge charbonneau avait dit quand
elle avait remis son rapport qu' il ne
s'exprimerait pas publiquement mais
michel comment expliquer cette
différence d'interprétation entre les
ducs est qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
sa ba écoute et quand le rapport est
sorti moi je comprenais pas comment
monsieur lachance avec ce qu'on voyait
là dans le rapport est ce qu'on avait
entendu à la commission comment il
pouvait nier qu'ils aient un lien au
moins indirecte entre l'octroi des
contrats et financement du parti
politique des partis politiques mais
quand on on y est surtout le parti
libéral et quand on lit les courriels là
on a l'impression que monsieur lachance
a littéralement voulu faire disparaître
la preuve qu'ils amenaient à conclure
qu'il y avait un lien comme s'ils
voulaient s'assurer que y'a rien dans le
rapport qu'ils puissent infirmer une
conclusion que lui avait il déjà tiré au
départ alors c'est extrêmement troublant
ça ressemble vraiment à du sabotage
tâche à marie maude denis disais tout à
l'heure lui il avait une conception
différente de leur rôle de ce qu'ils
devaient faire
lui voulait juste dénoncer les
stratagèmes pour exposer les stratagèmes
elle voulait quand même répartir la
responsabilité de ce stratagème
oui mais je pense écoute c'est sûr que
c'est un rapport
c'est pas un procès c'est un statut
légal très différents mais quand même
s'il ya du blâme à m le rapport c'est la
place de le faire écouter le rapport
gomery qui a été fait au fédéral a dit
des choses très fort à l'égard de
certaines personnes
c'est ça veut pas dire que ces gens là
vont être content et vont être
poursuivis mais quand même ça ouvre la
porte à sosa a ouvert une époque et je
pensais la même chose ici qu'il faut
dire si c'est pas seulement les
stratagèmes baisser les indices
les actes des individus qui sont
importants a pointé et c'est là il ya de
la matière allait plus loin le rapport
donne une base à se faire et maintenant
on va toujours se demander est ce qu'il
y avait des choses qui nous ont pas été
dit parce qu'elle est est ce qu'ils sont
allés aussi loin qu'ils auraient pu
aller ça c'est ça absolument daniel il
ya quand même sous 60 recommandations
200 rapports qui restent qui demeure et
qui sont unanimes alors est ce que
vraiment est-ce que c'est pas ça qu'il
faut retenir finalement c'est un aspect
important il ya eu aucun doute là dessus
sauf que dans dans la foulée de toutes
les commissions d enquête
prenez les une par une une à la fois et
vous verrez que très souvent la plupart
des recommandations restent lettre morte
on attend un peu au l'espace et le temps
arrange bien les choses et qu'on n'en
parle plus ça a été fait à plusieurs
reprises comme sur des questions de ce
docteur par exemple est peut-être le
plus bel exemple
donc ce serait d'autant plus facile pour
le gouvernement libéral de dire bon il
ya eu la dissidence de il ya eu certains
ménages s'était fait au niveau municipal
montréal et laval ont resserré leurs
règles d'octroi de contrats les anciens
maires sont partis et cetera
donc la commission a fait un travail
utile sauf que c'est la pression sur le
gouvernement libéral pour mettre en
oeuvre les 90 recommandations à les
drones métro b depuis la dissidence de
renaud lachance et avec sur bois
aujourd'hui michel est ce que ça donne
un prétexte pour ben écoutez moi je
pense que le gouvernement va mettre en
oeuvre un bon nombre de ses
recommandations là de toute façon mais
je pense qu'il y avait autre chose que
ce n'était pas simplement d'aboutir à
des recommandations
il y avait un exercice pédagogique le
général on voulait démontrer à la
société qu'on pouvait faire le ménage et
là toute sa dimension là c'est foutu
les genres sont vont rester sur
l'impression et c'est ça qui vont
retenir du rapport pas des
recommandations qu'il ya eu il ya eu de
la magouille là dedans et que même le
rapport l'aïe et de la magouille mais
dans le rapport et qu'on n'a pas fait le
ménage et ça c'est vraiment dommage
parce que des savates ça ne peut
qu'augmenter le cynisme
toute la classe politique et même le
fonctionnement de la société en général
et dans l'art de cynisme et parlons de
cynisme j'entendais midi j'ai mon ami
michel c'est au jeu quelques évoqué
france qui faisait yves boisvert de la
presse que bon maintenant que julie
boulet a été complètement exonérés
blanchi par la commission on pourrait la
ramener au cabinet dans un remaniement
qui pourrait survenir bientôt
c'est vous dire quel est l'état d'esprit
dans les rangs gouvernementaux
bon passons à la ottawa les faire un
petit tour là-bas parce que c'était
aussi la première semaine à la chambre
des communes de justin trudeau après
plusieurs voyages à l'étranger
il s'est occupé de plusieurs dossiers
évidemment l'arrivée des réfugiés
d'ailleurs ce soir il sera à personne
'l'annonce d'une consultation pour une
enquête publique sur la disparition et
l'assassinât d'une femme autochtone et
puis tâche à des baisses d'impôts pour
la classe moyenne qui se feront pas à
coût nul finalement ça va vous coûter 1
milliard 200 millions ce n'est pas prévu
ça s'est pas privée moi je les prévu
j'ai prévu plein d'idées et ce grande
surprise il n'y a pas un équilibre entre
ceux qui vont recueillir des gens plus
riches avec les augmentations et ceux
qui vont donner à la classe moyenne avec
les baisses d'impôts écoute n'est pas
une surprise mais c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour le gouvernement que ses
sorties et ses sorties aussitôt avant
même l'exercice budgétaire de l'année
prochaine on savait qu'il fallait passer
ses mesures d'impôts présenté avant la
fin de cette année mais quand même ce
pas une bonne nouvelle et je pensais le
commencement des promesses brisées
ça va pas ça va pas s'arrêter là 10 ans
ça oui il ya eu un peu ce changement
pour les réfugiés mais là c'est à dire
qu'elle tient ses promesses pour la
classe moyenne le déficit va être un peu
plus important que prévu son dû mais
daniel c'était faut s'inquiéter du fait
que les déficits tués et il faut
toujours s'inquiéter quand les cas les
déficits augmentent considérablement je
regarde la première semaine du
gouvernement trudeau ils ont été très
bons sur l'environnement à partir jouer
un rôle intéressant ramener sa unis pour
cent c'est extrêmement ambitieux trop
ambitieux
très bon sur les sur les armes
il règne comme nous tous
ils ont fait ils ont fait ce qu'il
fallait faire cette commission denquête
c'est beaucoup plus que symbolique ça va
être très important première étape
importante dans la réconciliation sur
les réfugiés également john calame
impressionné beaucoup de gens et sur
l'économie ya des inquiétudes
si vous savez quand gouvernement la
banque du canada dit advenant une
récession pourrait en arriver à des
déficits à des taux d'intérêt négatifs
c'est peut-être pas très rassurant et on
a déjà engagé de la part du gouvernement
trudeau 2 milliards pour l'environnement
il ya deux ou trois milliards du premier
pour des autochtones des réfugiés ça va
coûter beaucoup plus que prévu
on est rendu à 4,5 milliards et on n'a
pas encore dépensé un seul sou pour des
infrastructures qui était l'objectif
principal de ces déficits renoncer
l'économie stimuler l'économie avec des
difficiles autour de 10 milliards
alors il ya des gens qui s'inquiètent et
avec raison une chance au courant ça
juste un mois quand même qu'ils seront
pouvant michel il ya un problème
politique disons pour monsieur trudeau
parce que il est pas responsable de la
tournure de l'économie mondiale mais là
il rêve je pense qu'ils auraient pu
faire un calcul plus plus juste sur les
effets de la baisse de l'impôt pour la
classe moyenne mais il ya une erreur
d'un point 2 milliards une somme qu il
ya des gens qui ont tourné les coins
ronds mais pour ce qui est du du déficit
a nettement si monsieur trudeau réussi
ce qu'il dit c'est à dire que en fin
d'exercice
le ratio entre la dette et le pib baisse
et qu'on revient à l'équilibré
budgétaire à la fin du mandat que le
déficit soit 2,15 milliards entre les
deux c'est pas trop inquiétant mais le
problème c'est que là c'est pas sûr
qu'on va arriver à zéro en bout de ligne
michel j'habite en ontario la province
ah oui on va l'équilibré dans deux ans
trois ans et toujours pas équilibré ils
ont pour son pouvoir depuis 2003 et le
déficit qui est rentré après la
récession elle est toujours là et s'il
est beaucoup de gens se disent que c'est
la même histoire qui se répète la même
histoire qui s'est fait ici en 2003
comme séméga a hérité d'un déficit
à briser ses promesses là dessus et
l'ontario ça va très très mal
alors j'espère que ça va passer ses
nerfs mais les gens sont là je veux bien
que tu as charges comprend qu'il
faudrait éventuellement revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire mais si il est
vrai et c'est un gros si que le monsieur
au que le ratio entre la dette et le pib
continue à descendre ben ça c'est pas
une catastrophe si on peut garder
quelques secondes parler des choses
sérieuses quand même parce qu'on dirait
une photo qui a fait beaucoup jaser
depuis deux jours cette photo dans le
magazine vogue de justin trudeau et de
sophie grégoire tours d'eau et donc est
ce qu'il en fait trop évidemment il est
très sollicité à l'étranger on s'en est
rendu compte quand il était à paris
michel est ce que ces trouvailles je
comprends la curiosité qui a des vies
des médias quinquin vous êtes toujours
pris avec angela merkel puis vladimir
poutine bien sûr c'est pas très sexy et
alors là il ya il ya quelqu'un
d'intéressant qui se présente alors ils
ont tous sauté dessus mais je me
souviens que son père était extrêmement
populaire nous aussi à l'époque et le
problème la différence c'est que
monsieur trudeau père pouvait se
permettre des légèretés comme cela
personne de tête sont à ta de son
envergure intellectuelle
le fils a encore à la démontrer alors il
faut pas qu'ils donnent l'impression
d'être un homme léger
futile mais mais l'important c'est ce
qui va arriver en bout de ligne le sig
gouverne bien ça nous dérangera pas
d'eux qu'ils fassent les les magazines
de mode il nous reste quelques leçons 10
secondes chacun tâche à daniel aubert ok
je pense écoute que le roi soleil save
us présentement mais dans 2 3 ans à
risque d'être une très grande différence
est très mauvaise histoire
on va voir moi je trouve que c'est une
magnifique photo ça me rappelle
plusieurs photos de michelle et barack
obama à peu près inchangée même contexte
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec michel
j'imagine mal andrée à un gala merkel
avec son conjoint lui tenant le bas du
dos ça ne marche pas ouais mais là c'est
là la première de magazines chez la
femme la plus influente et leurs tifosi
mais je pense qu'en cas se prêter à ce
genre de jeu là beaucoup avouent 3 on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour notre
bilan enfin jeudi prochain marqués